So Donald Trump, you have to see this. Donald
Trump said during a strange press conference
in India that, uh, he said a lot of different
things and I want to review some of the highlights
or maybe I would call them the low lights
with you because there's just so much here.
And where I want to start is that Donald Trump
asserted that two Supreme court justices should
recuse themselves from any case that in any
way involves Donald Trump or his administration.
It's Ruth Bader Ginsburg because she didn't
support him in 2016. Therefore, she should
not be allowed to be part of any decision
at the Supreme court that has anything to
do with Trump or his administration. And then
Sonia Sotomayor should also recuse herself
because of an inappropriate comment she made,
which Donald Trump when asked about this won't
actually cite or name. This is a couple minutes
of video, about 90 seconds. Let's take a look
at it together.
Mr president, did you just address coronavirus
um, so I will put that aside for the moment
you tweeted about justice Sotomayor, uh, yesterday
saying that she and justice Ginsburg should
recuse themselves from future cases dealing
with the administration. What is the basis
for your opinion on that? Well, it's very
obvious. I mean, I always thought that frankly
that justice Ginsburg should do it because
she went wild during the campaign when I was
running. I don't know who she was for. Perhaps
she was for Hillary Clinton. I couldn't believe
it. But she said some things that were obviously
very inappropriate. G later sort of apologized.
I wouldn't say it was an apology, but she
sort of apologized. And then justice Sotomayer
said what she said yesterday, you know very
well what she said yesterday is a big story
and I just don't know how they can not recuse
themselves or anything.
Having to do with Trump or Trump related,
uh, the right thing to do is that now is the
Supreme court justice is a different standard,
but at the same time, I think it's a higher
standard in a certain sense. So they'll have
to decide what to do. But her statement was
so inappropriate when you're a justice of
the Supreme court and it's almost what she's
trying to do is take the people that do feel
a different way and get them to vote, uh,
the way that you would like them to vote.
I just thought it was so inappropriate. Such
a terrible statement for a Supreme court justice.
What was inappropriate about the statement?
I'm not an attorney, so I can't really look
into what these bed was. John, she seemed
to criticize the white house for running to
the Supreme court at the drop of a hat to
seek, no, I don't think that was it. But I
think what she did say is she's trying to
shame the way I look at, he's trying to shame
people with perhaps a different view.
So understand that on this basis, Brett Kavanaugh
and Neil Gorsuch should recuse themselves
from any case involving Donald Trump and his
administration because Trump selected them.
How could they possibly be unbiased interpreters
of the law? How could they merely apply the
law to the facts when they know that they
are only there because of Donald Trump? If
the case has to do with Trump or his administration,
they should recuse themselves as well. Right,
and the point I'm trying to make is that you
can't have it both ways. Either the personal
opinions of judges don't matter. They are
simply conduits that apply the law to the
and the facts that come before them or they
are biased. Partisan actors whose biases have
to be sort of monitored and babysat and they
must be pulled off of any case where their
personal lives intertwined with the fact if
it's the former, then Ruth Bader Ginsburg
and Sotomayor are allowed of course to be
on the court when the case is relate to the
Trump administration because Gorsuch and Kavanaugh
are allowed.
If it's the latter, then any justice selected
by Trump would be too biased to be in on a
case that involves the Trump administration
in any way, shape, or form. It's illogical
as are most things involving Donald Trump.
Continuing on with the press conference in
India, I got many emails from people saying,
Trump appears to be high on something during
this one that that's not unique sentiment.
I don't know. We don't know at this point
what the guys on Trump at one point was asked
about. Harvey Weinstein. Trump has partied
with Harvey many times, but when asked about
the Weinstein guilty verdict, which we'll
discuss on today's bonus show, Trump says
he was never a fan of Harvey doesn't like
them, and sorry for the poor audio, so some
of these clips have very, very distorted audio.
I apologize
then with the daily mail.com I was wondering,
do you think justice was served in the Harvey
Weinstein case?
So I was never a fan of Harvey Weinstein,
as you know. In fact, he said he was going
to work hard to defeat me in the election.
How did that work out? By the way. I'm trying
to figure that out. Uh, he, uh, he was a person
I didn't like in a light. I don't know too
much about the case. Bring traveling and being
at meetings almost every hour of the day,
every minute of the day. I haven't been able
to really see too much of it, but I was just
not a fan of his, I, I knew him a little bit,
not very well. I knew him because he was in
New York. Uh, not, not a person that I like.
I will say the people that liked him were
the Democrats. Uh, Michelle Obama loved him.
I loved him.
So definitely downer. Trump at this press
conference, doesn't like Harvey Weinstein.
Then Trump got into the phase of the press
conference during which he brags about war
crimes, saying that we took oil and gas. We
took oil rather not oil and gas. We took oil
from Syria and we have soldiers guarding the
oil.
Oh, Al Qaeda. Last week you saw what happened
there. So nobody's done more than what I've
done. And, uh, but I, at the same time, Russia
should do it. Uh, ranch. Dude. IRAC should
do it. Uh, serious. You do it in a, we're
in a different part of the world. We're doing
it. Everybody says you're the only ones that
can do it. Well, at some point, these other
countries, I mean, a ranch should do it. Iran
hates ISIS and they should do it. And we've
done a great job. We've taken our soldiers
essentially out of Syria, except a little
hotspots that we forget. You know, we'll do
that develop. But, uh, we've taken the oil
and the soldiers that we have, they're the
ones guarding DOL. We have DOL
now understand that every time Trump says
we've taken the oil, he might be lying. Like
it might just be another Trump lie. But if
it's true, it is considered a war crime. If
us troops or us corporations take oil from
Syria without Bashar Al Assad's permission,
it is a war crime that is called pillaging
according to legal experts because the land
and its resources doesn't belong to us. It
belongs to Syria. Now I don't like Assad,
but if Trump takes oil without Assad's, okay,
that is pillaging and pillaging is a war crime.
Trump regularly admitting if he's telling
the truth to a war crime, he might be lying
though. Then it gets really funny. Now, I'll
tell you, I am concerned about Corona virus.
It's serious. We're now up to more than 80,000
cases that we know about. China may be hiding
tens of thousands of additional cases, 2,700
deaths as of this morning.
27 Oh seven was the official death toll as
of this morning, but Trump is a hypocrite
on coronavirus just like he's a hypocrite
on most things. Back in 2014 during the Ebola
scare, which had a huge political component
and it evaporated the day after the 2014 midterms,
it was used or Ebola was used as a proxy to
attack Barack Obama, and in fact, Trump did
this tweeting back in 2014 quote, Ebola patient
will be brought to the U S in a few days.
Now I know for sure that our leaders are incompetent.
Keep them out of here in all caps. During
this press conference in India, just hours
ago, Donald Trump hilariously had that tweet
read to him by a reporter and was asked, coronavirus
patients are coming to the United States.
Isn't this a double standard? Listen to Trump's
answer again, I apologize for the audio breakup.
Some of these clips, just something wrong
with the recording, it's not on our end and
Trump wildly claims that back in 2014 no one
had even heard of Ebola, which is obviously
untrue.
[inaudible] coronavirus specifically mr president,
2014 when the Ebola situation was very concerning
to so many Americans, you tweeted, Ebola patient
will be brought to the U S in a few days.
Now I know for sure that our leaders are incompetent
and all caps. He wrote, keep them out of here.
More than 20 Americans have now been brought
back to the United States with Corona virus.
By your own measure, does that mean that your
government has been incompetent? Are you pleased
with the response? In case you didn't know
between Ebola and coronavirus? Big, big difference.
It's like day and night. And I felt that we
should bring them back. They're Americans.
We should bring them back with Ebola. Uh,
it was, it's very explosive. It's very terrible.
We're making Trump try. Johnny Bolin with
the things that we're doing is, you know,
isn't some of the money you're led? Sorry,
please answer the question, but there's a
tremendous as a vast difference then around
14 or 12. Uh, and at that time nobody had
ever even heard of Ebola or ever conceived
of something where you basically, people would
disintegrate and uh, it was still working
on Ebola.
Listen to that. No one had even heard of Ebola
in 2014. What is he talking about? These are
the sort of off the cuff rants of an ignorant,
mad man looking to justify his own hypocritical
behavior. Now the reality is, yes, Ebola is
different than Corona Corona virus. Ebola
has a higher death rate than Corona virus,
but Corona virus is passed. It's transmitted
much more easily because Corona virus can
be passed through the air through droplets
sneezes, coughs. Ebola spreads only through
direct contact. So it's much easier to transmit
Corona virus than Ebola. I'm not suggesting
that Americans with Corona virus not be allowed
back into the country. What I'm pointing out
is Trump's hypocrisy and really the differences.
Obama was president when it was Ebola. Trump
is president now when it's Corona virus. That's
really the only difference. So another day,
another embarrassing press conference for
Trump as we showed you earlier, the India
trip, not going super well, a massive Indian
crowd of 100,000 literally running to the
exits, crowding the exits. As Donald Trump
spoke yesterday, that video is hilarious.
The press conference is disturbingly odd.
Another bad trip for Donald Trump,
figuratively and literally depending on your
opinion of Donald Trump's, uh, possible drug
use. Bad trip takes on another meeting. Let
me know what you think. I'm on Twitter at
D Pacman. Quick break back after this,